after joining google in 2004 sundar
pachai became the chief executive
officer of google in 2015. after the
creation of alphabet google's parent
group it took sundar just four years to
become the chief executive officer of
alphabet despite his meteoric rise from
the populist city of chennai in india to
the height of the tech industry sundar
has still managed to be one of the most
liked ceos in silicon valley in this
video we'll be looking at what a day and
sundar pichai's life looks like and
maybe just maybe we'll see why he has a
96 approval rating on glassdoor and is
known as the mr nice guy of silicon
valley
you're a nice guy welcome back to our
channel if you haven't already make sure
you hit the subscribe button and ring
that bell so you're notified every time
we upload a new video
morning routines the sun rises sundar
wakes up between 6 30 and 7 a.m in the
morning this is just around elon musk's
and mark zuckerberg 7 a.m and 8 a.m
respective wake-up times but it's not as
early as jeff bezos and tim cook who
wake up by 5 am and 3 45 am respectively
compared to tim cook sundar pichai's 7
am wake up time is pretty fair and
pretty normal what's not normal though
is the ceo of alphabet the company
that's supposed to lead us into the
paperless age reading his news from a
newspaper every morning that's right mr
sundar reaches for a print copy of the
daily wall street journal to digest
business news and updates however he
does also check the new york times
online as well next he takes his
breakfast which is usually an omelet
seems pretty basic or boring but the
natural combination of nutrients like
choline tryptophan vitamin b12 and iron
all help in reducing anxiety risk and
depression as well as aiding sleep not
to mention it helps with weight
management so it's no wonder that sundar
has a healthy slim build and is in a
good state of mind to run one of the
most important companies in the history
of humanity he also adds that he likes
to maintain his very english habit of
drinking a cup of tea in the morning
this english habit being the effect of
indian colonization by the british
according to pachai i'm not a morning
person so i need my time with my paper
and tea to wake up and kind of get going
so he doesn't work out in the morning
instead he picks out a casual but put
together outfit that has once been
described as banana republic dad
meetings
unlike elon musk who has strict
restrictions on his meetings or jeff
bezos who likes to have his meetings
only in the morning sundar pachai is
always ready to attend meetings that are
necessary in fact he sometimes takes
meetings on the go when he can it is
said that he can wander away during a
meeting if a problem that needs solving
is posed only to come back in a short
time with a solution that the team can
discuss this is because sundar claims
that he loves to pace when working on
something i love to pace and actually to
think i have to start walking apparently
during meetings he has the habit of
keeping quiet and waiting for everyone
to speak while he listens at the end of
the comments he then throws out ideas
that people could work on
interaction with work and employees
sundar pichai's meeting style of
listening before talking is just a
reflection of his leadership style which
everyone loves in fact an ex-google
employee martine huffed who worked as a
technical program manager under the
sundar run android department had this
to say if there's anybody that could
take over a ceo one day i would see
sundar as being a great choice for doing
that that was in 2014 just a year before
sundar pachai actually got appointed as
the ceo of google hoofed explained this
by comparing sundar with the former ceos
saying that larry is not afraid of
setting an audacious goal whereas i
think sundar is more of a great operator
he can assemble the team he can appoint
the right people and he's the one that
makes it happen that's not to say that
sundar doesn't have any product vision
current projects
and we do know that sundar does have
product vision simply by recalling some
of the new features that were discussed
in google's io keynote in may 2021 this
includes improvements to the google
search bar and its function as well as
their research and development interests
in things like lambda ai and sycamore
google's quantum computer lambda ai
stands for language model for dialogue
applications and is built on the novel
neural network for language
understanding called transformer using
deep learning ai it makes interactions
with technology more natural real and
meaningful plus you can even simulate
conversations with people and things
that are not really there for example if
you wanted to know how sundar chai
spends his day you could simply ask well
sundar pachai on your device you could
even simulate a conversation with a
paper plane or let pluto defend itself
on being or not being an actual planet
with google sycamore it's a whole new
game of bringing in a new way of
processing data that our current
computers aren't used to google recently
achieved quantum supremacy by performing
calculations on its quantum computer
called sycamore however sundar and the
team are constantly working on
developing an error-corrected quantum
computer with enough quantum bits that
will be able to surpass the
computational power of the universe in
theory we'd be able to solve complex
problems on drugs financial analysis and
security office and lunch sundar's
office space has been described as being
clean to the point of being spartan this
is important as it eliminates clutter
thereby reducing the amount of things
that you can possibly be distracted by
it's kind of similar to mark
zuckerberg's decision to wear just great
t-shirts jeans and sneakers every day to
work according to mark it helps him have
fewer decisions to make so that he can
actually focus on the most important
ones and we can see that it works for
both mark and sundar when it comes to
lunch as a vegetarian sundar is also a
nice guy to animals except you know when
he eats their unborn babies in the
morning evening routine
when sundar is done with work he heads
straight home and unlike a lot of the
richest ceos in the world he makes it a
rule not to take work home in fact he
doesn't test google prototypes in his
home as well i i do the prototypes that
work try to keep things simple at home
his home is an almost ten thousand
square foot mansion situated on just
over three acres of land in los altos
hills california observers have called
the house modest for someone of his
caliber but we're sure sundar is
satisfied with his infinity pool and
other amazing features of the house that
he and his family can enjoy and
sometimes he also engages in some of his
favorite recreational activities like
cricket and soccer he has said that when
he does any workout he does it at night
when he's back from work he lives in the
home with his wife anjali pichai and
their two kids oh and they have a dog
named jeffrey too sundar strives to get
back home to tuck his kids in every
night by himself this is a promise he
made to himself back in 2015. when he's
done for the day sundar goes to sleep